>>> EVERYBODY IS DOING IT BUT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
I'M MICHAEL SMERCONISH IN
PHILADELPHIA.
CNN IS DOING IT.
INDIANA UNIVERSITY AND MY SON'S
SCHOOLS ARE DOING IT.
THE LARGE HADDEST HOSPITAL
SYSTEM, SO WHY NOT THE LARGEST
EMPLOYER, THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
WHY WITH THIS VACCINE HESITANCY
IS PRESIDENT BIDEN NOT ORDERING
ALL MILLION FEDERAL EMPLOYEES
INCLUDING THE MILITARY TO GET
VACCINATED.
WE'RE IN THE MIDST OF A THIRD
WAVE OF COVID-19.
THE DELTA VARIANT IS DEADLY.
DEADLY FOR THOSE WHO REFUSE TO
BE VACCINATE D.
THERE ARE FEW LEFT WHO CAN BE
PERSUADED WITH SCIENCE AND
LOGIC.
EVERYONE HOSPITALIZED ACROSS
AMERICA FOR COVID OF-RELATED
ILLNESSES HAS ONE OTHER THING IN
COMMON.
THEY ARE UNVACCINATED.
SAID DIFFERENTLY, VIRTUALLY NO
ONE WHO HAS BEEN FULLY
VACCINATED FOR COVID IS IN THE
HOSPITAL WITH A COVID-RELATED
ILLNESS.
SO WHY ARE WE SUCCUMBING TO THE
INTRANSIGENCE OF THE UNWILLING
AND INSTEAD SEEKING TO PUNISH
THE RESPONSIBLE.
THOSE WHO HAVE DONE THEIR PART
BY GETTING VACCINATED.
TWO MORE REAL WORLD EXAMPLES OF
THE UNVACCINATED WERE IN THE
NEWS THIS WEEK.
HERE IN PHILADELPHIA THE
INQUIRER REPORTS AS MANY AS HALF
THE PLAYERS ON THE PHILLIES
REMAIN UNVACCINATED.
MEANWHILE, ERIC CLAPTON
THREATENED HE MIGHT REQUIRE
VACCINATION.
ON A SOCIAL MEDIA ACCOUNT HE
WROTE THIS, I WISH TO SAY I WILL
NOT PERFORM ON ANY STAGE WHERE
THERE'S A DISCRIMINATED AUDIENCE
PRESENCE UNLESS THERE'S A I
RESERVE THE RIGHT TO CANCEL THE
SHOW.
I AGREE WITH MY FRIEND AND
COLLEAGUE THE LAWYER AND LAW
PROFESSOR SHANNON SPECKER WHO
WROTE A PIECE THIS WEEK TITLED
"IT'S TIME TO CHANGE THE DELTA
ON THE DELTA."
AND IN IT HE WROTE THIS, THE DAY
FOR EFFECTIVE PUBLIC SERVICE
ANNOUNCEMENTS BY BASKETBALL
COACHES AND 18-YEAR-OLD POP
STARS IS OVER.
IT'S OBVIOUS THAT THEY HOLD NO
SWAY OVER THOSE WHO PASSED ON
VACCINATION IN THE MANY MONTHS
IT'S BEEN GENERALLY AVAILABLE.
LET'S NOT WASTE ANYMORE MONEY OR
ENERGY ON THAT.
HE GOES ON TO ARGUE IF THE
ADMINISTRATION MADE IT MANDATORY
FOR THE 9.4 MILLION FEDERAL
EMPLOYEES, IT WOULD SPUR MORE
GOVERNORS AND MAYORS TO DO THE
SAME FOR THEIR 7.1 MILLION
WORKERS, WHICH IN TURN WOULD
NORMALIZE IT AND EMBOLDEN MORE
PRIVATE EMPLOYERS TO DO LIKE
WISE.
AS "THE NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTED
ON JULY 1, PRESIDENT BIDEN COULD
LEGALLY REQUIRE MEMBERS OF THE
MILLION TEAR TO GET VACCINATED,
BUT SO FAR HE HAS DECLINED TO
EXERCISE THAT POWER EVEN AS THE
HIGHLY CONTAGIOUS DELTA VARIANT
HAS BECOME AB INCREASING THREAT
TO UNVACCINATED AMERICANS.
THE MILITARY HAS WORKED HARD TO
COMBAT VACCINE MISINFORMATION IN
ITS RANKS SINCE THE SHOTS FIRST
BECAME AVAILABLE.
MORE THAN 80% OF THE SERVICE
MEMBERS ARE UNDER 35.
THAT'S A GROUP THAT OFTEN VIEWS
ITSELF AS IMPERVIOUS TO
INFECTIONS.
MANY WORRY THAT THE VACCINES ARE
UNSAFE OR DEVELOP TOO QUICKLY OR
WILL AFFECT FERTILELY.
THE TIMES REPORTED THE
PERCENTAGE OF THE DIFFERENT
BRANCHS THAT HAD GOTTEN AT LEAST
ONE SHOT AS FOLLOWS.
NAVY, %.
ARMY, 70%, A AIR FORCE, 61%,
MARINE CORP. JUST 58%.
IT'S ALL BETTER THAN THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE, BUT NOT WHAT
IT SHOULD BE.
ALTHOUGH THE FDA APPROVAL WAS
KROOITED AS TO WHY THEY COULDN'T
REQUIRE CORONAVIRUS
VACCINATIONS, AS THEY DO FOR
OTHER INOCULATIONS, "THE TIMES"
REPORTED UNDER FEDERAL STATUTE
THE OPTION TO REFUSE MAYBE WAVED
ONLY BY THE PRESIDENT IF IT WAS
DETERMINED THAT REFUSING IS NOT
IN THE INTERESTS OF NATIONAL
SECURITY.
WE'RE CERTAINLY AT THAT POINT
NOW.
AND IN MAY, THE U.S. EQUAL
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITY
COMMISSION ITSELF SAID THAT AN
EMPLOYER CAN LAWFULLY REQUIRE
EMPLOYEES TO OBTAIN A
VACCINATION AS A CONDITION OF OF
RETURNING TO THE WORKPLACE SO
LONG AS THE EMPLOYER REASONABLY
ACCOMMODATE EMPLOYEES WHO ARE
UNABLE OR UNWILLING TO GET
VACCINATED BECAUSE OF DISABILITY
OR SINCERELY HELD RELIGIOUS
BELIEF.
SO PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS THE
POWER.
WHY ISN'T HE USING IT?
INSTEAD CNN REPORTED THIS WEEK
THAT AS THE DELTA VARIANT
SPREADS, THE WHITE HOUSE AND CDC
ARE CONSIDERING REVISING MASK
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR VACCINATED
AMERICANS.
THAT'S BACKWARDS.
WE AREN'T MANDATING THAT THE
UNVACCINATED GET THE JAB.
INSTEAD THE IDEA IS NO TO MAIN
DANE MORE MASKS INCLUDING FOR
THOSE WHO ARE VACCINATED.
BUT THAT LOGIC WE DON'T KNOW WHO
IS VACCINATED SO WE SHOULD
REQUIRE A MASK OF EVERYONE.
INSTEAD OF UM POSING FURTHER
UPON THE VACCINATED, LET'S
INSTEAD UP THE PRESSURE ON THE
UNVACCINATED.
ON THURSDAY THE NFL ANNOUNCED
THAT IF THERE'S COVID-19
OUTBREAK AMONG UNVACCINATED
PLAYERS, A GAME CANNOT BE
RESCHEDULED AND THAT TEAM WILL
BE FORCED TO FORFEIT RESULTING
IN LOST WAGES AND A LOSS FOR
PLAYOFF SEEDING THE NFL IS
RIGHT.
MAYBE AN MLB POICY WOULD GET
MORE OF THE PHILLIES VACCINATED.
AND A SIMILAR EXAMPLE SHOULD BE
SET BY PRESIDENT BIDEN IN
REQUIRING ALL FEDERAL EMPLOYEES
TO GET THE JAB.
AND THE SAME SHOULD APPLY TO
GOVERNORS AND MAYORS.
IN SAN FRANCISCO MAYOR LONDON
BREED DID JUST THAT FOR ALL
35,000 CITY EMPLOYEES AND THE
POLICY HAS NOT BEEN MET WITH ANY
SIGNIFICANT RESISTANCE.
CITY EMPLOYEES THERE HAVE UNTIL
JULY 29 TO REPORT THEIR STATUS
AND NO LATER THAN TEN WEEKS
AFTER THE FDA GIVES FINAL
APPROVAL TO ONE VACCINE TO GET
VACCINATED.
WAITING UNTIL FINAL APPROVAL,
THAT'S NOT NECESSARY, BUT AT
LEAST IT'S A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
ON THURSDAY ALABAMA'S REPUBLICAN
GOVERNOR ADDRESSED THE FACT THAT
HER STATE HAD SEEN NEARLY 10,000
NEW CASES THIS THE PAST TWO
WEEKS AND THAT ONLY 33.9% OF
RESIDENTS ARE FULLY VACCINATD.
THAT'S LESS THAN ANY OTHER
STATE.
ASKED IF SHE MIGHT MANDATE
MASKS, SHE SAID NO.
THE ANSWER IS VACCINATION.
>> FOLKS ARE SUPPOSED TO HAVE
COMMON SENSE.
BUT IT'S TIME FOR THEM TO BLAME
IT ON THE UNVACCINATED FOLKS.
IT'S THE UNUNVACCINATED FOLKS
THAT ARE LETTING US DOWN.
>> SHE'S RIGHT AND SHE SHOULD
REQUIRE HER STATE'S EMPLOYEES TO
GET THE JAB.
SO TOO IN NEW YORK CITY.
FRONT PAGE OF "THE NEW YORK
TIMES" TODAY.
THE NEWS THAT MAYOR DE BLASIO IS
URGING NEW YORK BUSINESSES TO
REQUIRE EMPLOYEE VACCINATIONS.
HE'S AN EMPLOYER.
THE STORY SAYS, QUOTE, HE SAID
HE WOULD INTRODUCE SIMILAR
MEASURES FOR HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF MUNICIPAL
EMPLOYEES.
LET'S GET TO IT, MAYOR.
HERE'S THE BOTTOM HIEN.
THIS IS ABOUT WHICH PEOPLE IN
THIS COUNTRY ARE GOING TO
CONTROL VIRUS-RELATED BEHAVIOR.
THE UNVACCINATED OR THE
VACCINATED.
THERE WILL BE SOME LEVEL OF
CIVIL DISOBEDIENCE EITHER WAY,
BUT ALLOWING THE UNVACCINATED TO
CONTROL VIRUS POLICY, THAT'S
UNJUST AND UNHEALTHY.
IT IS TIME FOR GOVERNMENT TO
LEAD.
WHICH LEADS ME TO THIS WEEK'S
SURVEY QUESTION ON MY WEBSITE.
I WANT TO KNOW WHAT YOU THINK.
SHOULD PRESIDENT BIDEN MANDATE
ALL FEDERAL EMPLOYEES GET
VACCINATED?
JOINING ME NOW TO DISCUSS THIS
IS KATHLEEN SEBELIUS, FORMER
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE.
AND DIRECTOR OF THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION COLLABORATING
CENTER ON NATIONAL AND GLOBAL
HEALTH LAW, HE WROTE A GREAT
PIECE FOR MY WEBSITE THIS WEEK.
AND HE'S THE AUTHOR OF THE BOOK
GLOBAL HEALTH SECURITY, A
BLUEPRINT FOR THE TUCH.
PROFESSOR, YOU HAVE SAID THAT
THE LAW AND JUDICIARY HAVE
ALWAYS SUPPORTED IMMUNIZATION
UNTIL NOW.
THAT'S WHANGED?
>> WHAT'S CHANGED IS I HAVE
NEVER SEEN IN MY OWN 30 YOORZ OF
EXPERIENCE IN PUBLIC HEALTH THE
KIND OF POLITICIZATION.
JUST THE BASIC PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SCIENCE TOOLS, VACCINES, MASKS,
ALL OF THE KIND OF SIGNALS THAT
THE FORMER PRESIDENT GAVE.
NOW WE'RE SEEING A SPLIT IN OUR
COUNTRY THAT IT IS VERY SAD
BECAUSE THE VIRUS DOESN'T KNOW
POLITICAL PARTIES.
AND WE HAVE THE TOOLS WE REALLY
NEED TO USE THEM.
AND OUR BEST